[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's up
Christopher hey how's it going we're
doing good man what's up uh pretty good
so I'm in a relationship right now uh
everything's going great and I'm
planning on proposing uh maybe in the
next two weeks all right dude
congratulations thank you so there's a
little dilemma I guess so about I love I
love engagement dilemas Bring It On All
right so um previous I was in a
relationship previously before the one
on in now and I was engaged to the uh
girl and she gave me back the engagement
ring oh don't do it don't do
it I was thinking about just
using
r no dude I just does your girlfriend
know about this past
engagement no oh boy okay number one
have that combo first oh no no no no no
no she knew I was in yeah she knew I was
engaged before yeah she so do you not
think she's gonna her first question is
gonna be wait is that the ring
from I I know I just don't want to spend
extra money on it because
chis going to a different the moment you
slide that ring on her finger her her
finger will catch
fire okay like it will just electrocute
her and then by proxy you'll end up dead
that's just how this that's how this
will work dude don't do this you're
going to pay you're going to lose your
like both butt cheeks when you resell
this ring you will lose your butt and
that's okay okay it's called it's called
Uh uh that sucks tax and just spend it
dude do not regift an engagement
ring okay all right it's just it's just
too much bad juju and I'm not very you
know I'm not that guy John I don't do
the whole uh you know AST astrology and
all this stuff and I'm like well I just
feel like there's too much sentimental
value tied up in this ring from a past
relationship that fell apart that didn't
work out you're going to be feeling that
emotionally she's going to be thinking
that in the back of her head and then
it's going to spark a giant fight and
you're going to have to get a new ring
anyways and you better hope that
relationship even survives that
fight I don't know how I don't think
either of John and I's wives would react
kind if that was the situation and I
think that would be my wife's first
question it just kills me to spend more
money but okay you know what's going to
kill you also your fiance when she finds
out that you got the got a ring except
she's gonna kill you for real what is
what's a new ring gonna
cost well I guess I'll probably get
another one for 2K to 3K does it have to
be a 3K
ring I think for it to look decent I
guess I don't know man they've got some
rings out there these these days on Etsy
that are gorgeous and they're not the
you know a full carrot real diamond it
might be mois andite or something but I
think it's more about the thoughtfulness
behind it versus and especially not
giving her a real diamond ring that was
meant for a real past
fiance okay take a fake ring any day
over that I'm just almost at the
$50,000 Mark at savings and just to see
that I'd be going back you have 50,000
in savings I have 48 000 I'm almost at
50,000 Chris why are you calling
us
Chris what are you doing with your life
This Woman's future she's going to be
can we go on the vacation and you're
like I almost have 50,000 in savings
woman leave me alone but I had this
coupon left over from my last
relationship I know let's call My Ex's
father-in-law he has a bedroom we can
rent out like for real dude man okay I
bite the bullet and get that new ring
and sell the old one for what you can
get for it and Hey listen like this is
just like a straight up like I I grew up
in Houston do you not have some like
buddies there that you could have run
this question by that would have just
knocked you upside the
head well well I do but they love to
spend money so I didn't really all right
that's fair that's fair that's I I
support that then thanks for calling two
Wise Guys and ask any woman that's also
a good indic ask I'm pretty sure a 99.9%
would say yeah don't do that hey I'm
gonna I'm going to do a litmus test
there is one woman on the front row in
the studio audience are we right okay
she just two thumbs up so and she's got
a ring on her finger so she's got
experience yes so thank you ma'am for
that no matter what don't oh geez don't
hey George this is awesome um not only
are we helping people get out of debt we
are now saving lives and PR homicide yes
we're doing it preventing homicide was a
stretch but I like it I like you're
going with it
I I'm sweating even thinking about
proposing to Whitney with a previous oh
my gosh